[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I can hardly believe it I used to come
here all the time as a boy
George yeah Edith alone on the town what
will she get up to so what do you think
I should do would you like a London life
the fact is I'd like a life I should let
the young ones console each other I just
want to be his friend Mrs Hughes we must
run this place as it should be rough who
has an under Butler these days I suppose
you've settled into the routine by this
time I think so I like it here Mission
shoes we don't think maybe you should
start calling me Elsie not here not
while we're working oh dear I do hope I
haven't cast a shadow what did you think
you were doing sprinkling Sunshine so
you want to protect your power at the
expense of the patients I want to
protect the patients at the expense of
my par and may the best man win
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ty towards Alfred the Kingdom of Wessex
surrender all birds
[Applause]
Kings will be made and Kings will die
the crown is all important I do not wish
to become king it is your duty tonight
Lord you will break your Earth I give
you glory
we must undo the past
You Must Destroy Alfred
[Music]
Ross poldark is alive
Francis is to be married who is it to be
Elizabeth
was there really nothing between us I
thought you were dead
they hurt you guys try on me mister
what's your name demille's a corn Ross
poldark
so much for my inheritance he's proved a
poor Legacy it's certainly a Fickle one
it's a Pity he owns nothing worth having
but when he does it will be my pleasure
to take it from him
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
with no one to blame yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the time has come for the social season
tighter she's
my name
not know me but
but no you
this is what they have been trained for
since birth which young ladies might
succeed at securing a match we've always
amused me Miss Bridgeton ever since I
was a school boy and you were oh but
I've
[Music]
faster facet Bridget come here old
friends this is my sister
how is it possible that there has not
been a single betrothal yet I wish to be
entertained we find ourselves seated
beside
deciding I'd like to think you're happy
about that it would be better if you
were friends when thinking about me at
all I'm aware of your reputation I'm
anything but interested in you I
anything interested in you
must our only options be to squawk and
settle or to never leave the nest what
if I want to fly
lady whistle down has all but declared
me ineligible whistle down whistle down
whistle down if I'm unable to find a
husband I shall be ruined perhaps there
is an answer
[Music]
ing indeed every presumptuous mother in
town will leave me alone and every
Suitor will be looking at you
let's turn to my eyes if this is to work
you must appear madly in love
the Duke truly has put your head in a
spin
and awful that I'm enjoying it
[Applause]
dear reader
reader the Scandal I shall uncover it
is more than just your honor at stake
that just because I'm a woman I'm
incapable of making my own choices
[Music]
there is nothing you cannot do
you are a Bridget
oh is this not lovely all of us together
again lovely indeed we should tempt
Scandal more often
when I sleep I dream and in my dream
someone wants to walk around
[Music]
none of the peaky blinders
[Music]
people think that I'm gonna fall who's
gonna take the throne we
bout around we have never even heard of
your paper so we are not afraid of your
threats they said that Tommy Shelby was
a span Force
spent in the head three
two
one
so Tommy Shelby that's what you want
that's water you shall have
[Applause]
there will be a war
and one of you will die
but which one I cannot tell Mr Shelby
you've come to my attention I will have
native men like you except there is no
other man like you sometimes killing is
a kindness
it will be Thomas Shelby who's crucified
and there will be no Resurrection
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
now you've heard of us
[Music]
do you ever feel as if everything's
pointing you towards something
nice
time
history
I am grateful every day we have
whatever tomorrow brings
[Music]
it is a blessing you came to me
Colonel Fraser the time has come for you
to fulfill your oath do not disappoint
me
foreign
it would be safer in your time you want
to go back don't you our family is here
you are my family
I need to know what's causing their
illnesses isn't this playing God
I swear enough to the ground but I will
not stand by and watch my kin killed
people consider this to be the spark of
the American Revolution if we start this
fight now America will never become
America
promise Jamie
[Music]
promise me you're coming back
it's weird
[Music]
we kind of see what made before us
just as you give me your word I give you
mine
stand by my hand
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm happy to hear anyone's problems with
me
don't worry about the bodies I would
like to be useful to Russia to help its
greatness you'll burn my ears there is
no higher use rabbit
these sticks are to enhance your
fertility but I cannot work out whether
we wave them over your womb or insert
them into you I'm pretty sure it's a
wave-flim situation
together we could create a greater
Russia I rule you sir your bride is
unhappy you must clear the clouds we
should find you a lover
muscles
I like to be alone in the morning now we
shall create the day together with sunny
dispositions Fearless Hearts we shall
discuss whether or not to kill the
empress she is a strange creature who I
sense is at times laughing at me Empress
there are unhappy men here looking for a
leader if the emperor dies Russia goes
to the empress
[Music]
Russia must be saved and I with it
I don't want to kill you you're not a
bad person I could kill you you are a
bad person
you're funny treason is what we're
discussing here
it's a dangerous game
do not worry
all is bliss in the court of Catherine
the Great
[Music]
do you mean touche
this is science enjoy
[Music]
Liberal Party
you're the youngest man to lead a
British political party in more than a
century careful now I'm not sure
anybody's worth ending up in prison for
I was a victim my little bunny
if he's lost
[Music]
he will destroy me and the party and my
marriage
[Music]
so what would you like me to do
highly respected man it is alleged that
Thorpe and Mr Scott began a homosexual
Affair that's me Peter Taylor accuses
this is the story of a liar meeting a
fantasist and I'm not sure which ones
which
it's it's bloody knots
affected the art of hiding in plain size
there is only one way for us to survive
I will talk I will be heard and I will
be seen
you were amazing I was rude I was vile I
was queer I was myself
a very English Scandal on BBC One
everyone will always undress the match
you must make him pay for it
my darling beard
we lost
we lost like
perhaps the Golden Age of the Vikings is
gone
we need you to live to lead us
I'm here first
diverse with him
I don't think my destiny lies here
I have Ambitions
when they take off my bones
I want them to say here is the most
famous Viking who ever lived
[Music]
it's everything my father dreamed of
I'd rather died in return to Philly so
we commit our bodies to the Deep
I've been lost for so long
I abandoned the brother I love the most
and since it's my fate to kill you it
makes sense for me to stay with you I
suppose
we massively outnumbered you have just
give it up some of us will perish
death is a bliss
don't be afraid
I'm still alive I took you so long
I still claim to be Vikings don't act
like Vikings
come with me be like the Gods
[Applause]
it's impossible
I'm a middleman I take orders they do
the rest
I don't ask questions
[Music]
what exactly occurred in your residence
eight months ago Mrs Darmody
namic men killed
I didn't ask for trouble what was
brought to my doorstep I returned
he said you're dangerous
I suppose he meant
your boss
should be careful
one looks down in secret
and sees many things
Mr narcisse
Dr Nazis Mr Thompson I wish to deal with
you
I'd want this to be clear you and I
[Music]
we're not going to meet again
what brings you to town it's not exactly
National Secret
s only Kings understand each other
[Music]
what shall we do Mr Thompson
what shall we do
Spain
unite against our enemies so that my son
protected on his throne
[Music]
till that girl arrives
we are lost
I asked my mother once why I was not
afraid of my destiny she said I may as
well be fearful of my own reflection
I give to you Princess Catherine of
Aragon
only then can I protect Spain
[Music]
what happened to her
I'm succession is clear
may I introduce Prince Henry people call
me Harry
you are his brothers
I came here to 14 alliance with England
and that is what I'll do
to save my family
our alliance is in shreds
she's arrogant and overprivileged what
game does she play what makes you think
he's a game
I am the daughter of the greatest
moments this world has ever known
you challenge me
to him
[Music]
there's the rare occasion when the
public can be engaged on a level Beyond
flash if they have a deeper Bond
nostalgia
it's delicate but potent
it's a twinge
in your heart I missed
you I missed you too far more powerful
than memory alone
who are you I'm Peggy Olsen the new girl
it goes backwards got your whole life
ahead
[Music]
forwards I love you
oh my goodness it takes us to a place
took you so long
before we ache
to go again
it's the end of an era
Mad Men the final episodes begins Sunday
April 5th
only on AMC
ladies and gentlemen prepared to be
amazed
Avatar
murder
William sees crime as an as an intricate
puzzle
sir
prepare to be transported to a new world
a world where all your senses are
engaged
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I believe that the filmed Adventures of
detective William Murdock will play at a
standing room-only crowds from coast to
coast
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]